I guess I better explain this this anti
identity guy thing here I've been going
to the internet identity workshop twice
a year for the past eleven years when I
started going I realized that people
were often using identity for a proxy
for what they really wanted I mean it
wasn't this bad but it was almost like
the clerk at the Starbucks asked to see
your driver's license before taking your
six bucks I mean that's that's what it
seemed like to me so I started going
around and trying to educate people but
it was slow going and then about five or
six years ago I started putting that on
my badge and people who would come up to
me and I got to educate them so that
sped up the process and at this point
I've gotten several converts I've gotten
enough that I think at the iiw coming up
in April I'm going to say I'm an anti
identity guy instead of the anti day so
that's a sign of progress now this is a
very big subject here and I told Andy
that I need about seven hours but he
said you guys were unlikely to stick
around that long so there's some stuff
I'm not going to talk about not going to
talk about hardware attacks like ROH
hammer a side channel like Spectre and
knelt down I'm not going to talk about
protocol errors that led to heart bleed
or operating system attacks privilege
escalation man-in-the-middle like DNS
hijacking or the Starbucks blue van
story which I can tell you over dinner
I'm not going to talk about the crypto
like the TLS downgrade I'm probably not
going to talk about some other stuff
that's a lot not to be talking about so
what's left and is it interesting well
what I'm going to talk about is access
control I contend that without access
control we would never see any of the
other attacks because the bad guys could
do whatever they wanted far more easily
so in a sense access control is
fundamental to secure it and it's just
answering this
are you allowed to do what you're asking
to do it's a very simple question to ask
but if you look there are dozens of
companies out there selling you products
to help you answer that now how can
there be dozens of companies selling
products to answer a simple question
well it must be that it's really really
hard to answer then you should ask
yourself well why is it really really
hard and I hope to convince you today
that it's really really hard because
there's a fundamental flaw in the way we
do it alright so let's start I'm gonna
give you some examples of the mess we're
in now there's about 400 examples I
could give you I've selected so on your
computer on my computer and everybody's
computer there's this very powerful
program this program can read all your
files this program can encrypt all your
file it could read all your files and
send your secrets out on the internet it
can encrypt all your files and make you
scramble to get Bitcoin to pay the
ransom and yet even though this program
is so powerful there are people at your
work who use it every day some of them
for hours at a time it's not the
operating system I'll let you think for
just a second what it might be that
program has the power to do owes awful
things alright so so this program can do
all those horrible things and almost any
program you thought of can do the same
thing because every program you run runs
with all your permissions it's a mess
second one is sharing sharing I mean I'm
going to illustrate the problem with two
stories the first story mark asked me in
an emergency Mark asked me to park his
car in my garage I couldn't do it so I
asked my neighbor to do it for me
and told her to get the garage key from
my son when think twice about that story
second story in an emergency Mark asked
me to copy a file from his computer to
mine
I couldn't do it so I asked my neighbor
to do it for me and said to get access
to my computer from my son
now I see some smiles out there because
this is a ridiculous story this is just
inconceivable sharing is a mess chaining
anybody here use Netflix so I worked
with a guy who retired from Netflix his
biggest problem is his stock value was
going up faster than he can spend it
nice nice problem to have any rate he
told me that whenever you click anything
in Netflix anything at all you will be
invoking between a couple of dozen and a
couple of hundred microservices and
they're all chained together to satisfy
your request now that example is too
complicated for me to explain here so I
made up another example so here I am I'm
talking to my voice remote and I'm using
a third-party voice service think Alexa
hey Google whatever to do the
translation and then invoke either my
streaming service or my thermostat okay
and what I'm going to do is is my voice
remote will authenticate to the voice
service using my user ID and very strong
password
hey it's not password one right and then
the question is who's authentication is
it going to use when it invokes the
streaming service or the thermostat
there's only two choices it's or mine so
let's say it uses its own and I ask to
see somebody else's viewing history I
don't know who that guy might be but I'm
gonna ask to see his viewing history and
so the service sends it to the streaming
tonight my voice service sends it to the
streaming service and if that person has
an account with the same streaming
service and the same voice service the
voice Service necessarily needs
permission to make that request and so
the streaming service honors it but now
the voice service has no way of knowing
what the access policy of the streaming
service is I'm going to repeat that
because it's gonna come back later this
is a very important point the voice
service has no way of knowing what the
access policy is for the streaming
service so it sends it to me and I get
to see somebody else's viewing history
and that shouldn't have happened there's
a name for this it's called the confused
deputy vulnerability the voice service
has become a confused deputy if you've
never heard of it
you should learn about it because it's
everywhere clickjacking
a cross-site request forgery all kinds
of vulnerabilities are really confused
deputy and the wikipedia page is pretty
good but I highly recommend norm Hardy's
1986 article on it it's delightful and
it's where he coined the term all right
so it's not going to work using the
services credential so it's going to use
mine and let's say I asked to see this
movie I say seif Fahrenheit 451 and
voice wreck your aversion and and the
old one is better than the new one but
the voice service you know voice
recognition isn't perfect and instead of
hearing see it hears set and it sends it
to my thermostat and the thermostat says
Oh Allen wants to change the temperature
and I end up a pot roast
okay so chaining is a mess
[Music]
how about managing permissions there is
a push in the IOT world to give every
device a strong cryptographic identity
so we can use that identity for managing
permissions now when you look at this
picture I think you can understand why I
call that madness but I'll just give you
a simple example let's say I have a
smart door lock and I used the strong
cryptographic identity of my cleaning
lady smartphone to let her open my door
so she can come in and clean my house
and that works just fine until she gets
sick now she's got a choice
she can leave my house uncleaned or she
can give her phone to the substitute but
her phone's got a lot more than just the
ability to open my front door it's got
her banking and it's got her private
texts and it's got her Vegas photos
right she probably doesn't want to give
up that phone so managing permissions is
a mess all right those are the four
examples so how do we get here I'm about
to tell you something that you may find
surprising I know that I do I'm old
right every time I look in the mirror I
find that surprising but I guess it's
true right
so what how old am i well I wrote my
first computer program in 1963 one of
the guys at iiw saw that and he said oh
my god that's the year my mother was
born I'm so old that my PhD thesis is on
punch cards and I brought some with me
if we want to know why we call it files
because these things felt fit into
cabinets that look like file cabinets
and if you want to know the file system
its these lines we drew on the top to
separate the various pieces you come up
afterwards and get a closer look I am so
old that I am an IBM licensed keypunch
operator and when I got that card
obviously carried it around in my wallet
a little too long when I got that card I
went down to the phone company to get a
job because they were paying a buck and
a quarter an hour at a time when the
minimum wage was 75 cents and I walked
in and walked up to the counter
and I asked for a job application and
the lady sitting there looked up at me
and laughed and says we don't hire men
maybe I maybe I have a lawsuit maybe I
have a lawsuit I don't know so so I'm
telling you this because it means that I
lived through all the decisions that got
us into
this mess and so this is my personal
theory of what happened I think it holds
up pretty well so my story starts in the
mainframe era I like to think these two
ladies worked for the phone company they
were probably just models from some
advertising company but that's okay
and over here is a mainframe and you can
see the card reader here this is the
card reader and this thing right here
you could put that whole tray of cards
in there go through and read them right
in okay and so access control at that
point was you keeping me from fooling
around with your cards right and you
could get a box with a lock on it right
that was access control that was easy
well time marched on machines got disks
disk got big enough told your stuff and
my stuff at the same time and now we
needed a way to keep us apart
me from fooling around with your stuff
and the first thing we needed was a way
of expressing the access policy and
people came up with the idea of the
access matrix this was what Andy was
talking about and the way it works is Oh
each row is a subject I'm using
terminology from the orange book circa
1980 about the terminology and each
column is an object I'm using files here
but objects could be anything including
other subjects but it's just more
intuitive this way and at the
intersections you see the permission so
we can see here that Alice has read
permission to file three okay very
simple now those old machines were very
short on memory very short on storage
they didn't want to store the whole
thing so we compressed it and the
decision was made to compress along the
columns now that's the exact same data
but just compressed along the columns
and each column is an access control
list for that object
I'm going to give you a little tiny hint
right now about what's coming in the
talk
that's the fatal flaw that was the
mistake that led to all the trouble yeah
so the way this worked was Alice when
she wanted to read file 3 would prove
that she was Alice and the system would
look up in the access control list for
file 3
does she have permission to do what
she's asking to do in this case the
answer is yes and she she read the file
now that's kind of awkward to have to
prove that she's Alice every time she
wants to read a file and in fact every
time she wants to read the next piece of
the file you'd have to go through that
so we came up with the idea of a login
we gave every user a unique identifier
and asked them to share a secret with
the system so the unique identifier was
a user idea or user name and we called
the secret shared with the system a
password we had no clue what we were
doing back then I'll give you an example
Peter Newman told me the first time he
went to set up an account on a CDC
machine his credentials were rejected
because get this the password was
already in use I mean that's how bad it
was that's how little we knew about what
we're doing now we fixed that one in a
hurry but it just gives you an idea of
the state of knowledge at that time okay
so that worked ok that's I'm going to
call that the mainframe model the axon
ending frame access control model so
time marched on and we went to client
server and in those days a client yeah
well let's talk to take that on to the
questions he says he has a fundamental
disagreement about the problem is access
control and we'll talk about that later
okay so in those days the client was
another question well we'll get to that
it was in use by another user and that
was the problem
not in used by me only one machine right
there's only one computer it's a
mainframe right so we went to the
client-server model and in those days a
client was a mainframe that got shrunk
in the dryer but it could fit in a
normal office environment it was still a
pretty big computer okay and we needed
access control and so what we did was we
said look we got the mainframe model
let's just extend it to the client so
instead of everybody on the system
having a unique identifier we gave
everybody in the company a unique
identifier and they shared a secret with
the machine so we stretched the
mainframe model a teeny tiny bit but
even that was showing some fraying
around the edges when I joined HP in
1992 my user ID was a carp because carp
was owned by Sid carp in Colorado now
Sid and I never met we never used the
same computers to the best of my
knowledge and yet for the rest of my
career I couldn't be carp when I was at
HP and I'm such a tight-ass that drove
me crazy okay so even there we're seeing
a little fraying around the edges well
then people said look he it would be
really convenient if our business
partner and employees of our business
partners could use our computers and we
started giving them unique IDs and have
them set up passwords and that got
really out of hand very fast I went to a
talk once and the guy said at that time
Oracle had 80,000 employees and was
managing 300,000 I
identities of employees of their
business partners that's just not
manageable so we came up with the idea
of Federation we're gonna now going to
stretch the mainframe model across
companies not just across machines
within a company but across companies
and so you'll authenticate to your
company and then somehow will get all
the information needed to do the access
control here is the actual procedure for
preparing one service in your company
for use by employees of one business
partner okay
that's the steps you go through is it
any wonder that ping identity is
profitable because they'll do this for
you well then we got to the internet and
so when you logged into prodigy when you
set up an account at prodigy you got a
unique identifier right and when you set
up an account at AOL you got a unique
identifier but there were different
companies so it was unlikely that you
would have the same identifiers at both
right and then you shared a secret your
password with them and what they were
doing is when you logged in to prodigy
they were making you part of the prodigy
company when you logged in to AOL they
were making you part of the AOL company
but there was nothing to connect the two
to know that you were the same okay well
you know where this led to right if you
want to know why you have so many user
IDs and passwords it's because we
extended the mainframe access control
model to the Internet that's why all
right time marched on and we went to
micro services now I explained the micro
services and I explained why it couldn't
work but I also said Netflix uses it all
over the place so why am i country am i
contradicting myself am i obviously
wrong well remember what I said about
that one phrase the voice service had no
way of knowing the access policy of
streaming service so what we're doing
what Netflix does and what Facebook does
and Google does and everybody does with
their micro services they run them all
in the same trust domain they run them
all within their own company so they can
know the access policy of all the other
services they deal with but that is a
problem there's a wonderful essay
I think it's 1956 Leonard read called I
pencil it's only a few pages it's
delightful I recommend you read it the
point he makes is that nobody knows how
to make a pencil one company provides
the graphite in other the wood somebody
else the eraser a fourth one the little
Wiggy that goes around the top probably
somebody else assembles all the pieces
nobody knows how to make a pencil and
his point is that our economy
fundamentally depends on that can you
imagine if Netflix had to have a pencil
making Department and Google had to have
a pencil making Department and IBM had
to have a pencil making Department when
knowing how to do all those pieces and
combining the graphite cutting the trees
all that stuff all in-house but that's
what we are doing with our microservices
because we're using the mainframe access
control model we can't outsource to take
the benefit of the specialization that
our economy depends on I contend that
this is not only a drag on the
profitability of these companies I think
it's big enough to be a drag on the
economy as a whole all right now we're
getting to the world of IOT Dan and
we're gonna have a zillion devices so I
just want to ask you a simple question I
just bought your smart house now what
okay if you want to know the problem of
extending the mainframe model to IOT try
to figure out an answer of that question
all right what are we going to do about
it well remember I told you about the
fundamental flaw so let's go back and
undo that decision we're still going to
compress but we're going to compress
along the
it's still the exact same data but now
the way it works is when Alice logs into
the system she gets what's called a
c-list I'll explain what that means in a
minute and when she wants to read file 3
she will simply say do a read using the
thing that's the second item in my see
list and that points to file 3 it
designates file 3 and it authorizes
access to it so that's what she does
okay now in the original paper 1965 C
stood for capability but that word has
been hijacked it has too many meanings
now and it gets confusing but since it
refers to an object we can call it an
object remember that the orange book
1980s subject and object that's
referring to object so we can call it an
object capability what is it an object
capability is an unfortunate remission
to use the object it designates that's
it unfortunaltely ssin to use the object
that designates so how many people here
have ever used o caps have you ever
taken your car in for service did you
enter your drive the drivers license of
the mechanic in the access control list
for your car no you handed them one of
those right that is an unfortunate rants
furball permission to drive my car every
one of you is used in Oh cap you didn't
even know it
close enough close enough yeah close
enough close enough right I can't maybe
you could but I can't well there's
always a problem so for example if I can
hack the memory of the system with Rho
hammer I can Forge memory references so
there's always I'm alright have you ever
read or written a file on a computer
well the way it works is you don't just
read the file on the computer you'll
have to open it first and you that's
when your permissions are checked when
you do the open and you get back
something called a file handle a file
handle is an unfortunate transferable
permission to read or write the file
depending on how you opened it right now
early on capabilities were criticized
capabilities were criticized for being
not very performant and yet UNIX
introduced file handles to improve the
performance because you didn't have to
do access check on every read operation
have you ever gotten a Google Doc or a
Dropbox share now this thing here isn't
unforgeable but you'd be guessing a long
time before you figured it before you
got that one right so in this case
they've replaced unforgeable ax T with
unguessable ax T okay but it is the same
thing it is a unguessable transferable
permission to read that file it's an
okay how about face post posting to
Facebook I don't do that but plenty of
people do Facebook uses something called
OAuth or instead of putting the secret
in the URL they put it in the header now
this is a little bit less like an object
capability because the designation of
the thing is in the URL and the
authorization is in the header but as
long as you're careful to always keep
them together which they
book is it functions very much like a no
cab now one other point I want to make
is in case you think this is just purely
theoretical or I'm just talking to make
noise there are 5 million programmers in
the Salesforce ecosystem writing
applications in an oak app subset of
JavaScript everything done on Salesforce
now is in an object capability subset of
JavaScript this is real this works so
now let's look at the four examples so
now we're going to look at privilege so
now when I start solitaire I can just
give it permission give it an oak app to
read and write its history file and sure
it can embarrass me by showing that I
played solitaire 50 times yesterday but
that's about the worst and if and if it
runs cryptolocker
can only encrypt its own files it
doesn't have access to mine so that's a
lot better how about sharing well the
reason that second story was so
ridiculous is that there are six aspects
of sharing that we rely on in the
physical world that our online systems
don't support this comes from Marc
Stiegler so it's dynamic it's an
emergency there's no time to find in
this track down a sysadmin to change an
entry and an access control list its
attenuated Marc didn't have to give me
power of attorney over his life or even
his whole keyring he just gave me his
car keys it's chained I could pass that
car key on to my neighbor in fact I
could even further attenuate by giving
my neighbor only the valet key now
chaining an attenuation are very
important without chaining every private
in the Army is saying yes sir mr. Trump
and without attenuation that private
ends up with permission to launch nukes
so chaining and attenuation are
fundamental and yet our our Akal our
mainframe model doesn't support it
it's come
poseable my neighbor could take one
permission for me one key for me and one
for my son to complete the job
it's cross-domain there's Marc's domain
my domain my neighbor's domain my son's
domain and it just works and it finally
it's accountable in a very interesting
way if Marc finds a new scratch on his
car he knows to come after me he never
heard of my neighbour but think about
what the log file on your online systems
would say I would call up the sysadmin
and say please give us permission to do
this thing and then Alice did something
bad and the log file shows that the
sysadmin gave her permission but it
never shows she got permission because I
asked so we've lost responsibility
tracking in our current systems so let's
talk about chaining well if I'm using
oak caps I would just use my
my streaming service viewing history oh
cap and the streaming service would know
that I don't have permission to get that
guy's viewing history so it fails as it
should if my if my request to see this
movie accidentally goes off to my
thermostat my thermostat says well that
I don't recognise that okay I'm not
going to do it and I've stay comfortable
so that just works
well it could have been there any number
of reasons that could have meant mr. so
the question is how does it know that
it's a movie and the question was and
the answer is there could have been any
number of bugs in the air or hacking in
the in the voice service that caused it
to misdirect the request okay but I sent
my voice service sent it the the viewing
service oh cap sent it to the voice
service the voice service didn't have it
let's save it for the questions okay I
think I messed up my example is why but
who get a little fix that later okay now
what about IOT well I want to tell you a
story here first of all for the cleaning
lady it's very easy she's got a no cap
on her phone she can give the transfer
the Oh cap to the substitute and
everything just works that's the easy
part
many years ago I had been married about
six months and I knew the honeymoon was
over my bride said to me I'm mad at you
and I said Oh hon what did I do
and she said yes now being new at the
whole husband business I guessed and she
said that too now I learned from that
two things one is never guess and I
never guessed again and the second one
is don't anticipate objections from your
audience but I've broken that one a few
times and this is one of the times I'm
going to do it one of the objections to
this o caps thing is how can people
possibly manage all those fine grain
permissions just just drive them crazy
right well again Marc Stiegler had the
key insight if I want to edit a word
document on my Windows machine I double
click on you know the icon for a dot doc
docx file right and the system knows
that Microsoft Word to that at that file
well I can use that active designation
as an act of authorization to give
Microsoft Word the Oh cap the dead at
that
file now I'm going to give you another
example here let's say I'm driving along
you're driving along and you get a flat
tire and today what you do is you call
triple-a and you sit with your car until
the tires fixed
thirty five forty five minutes on the
side of the freeway I've done it
tomorrow what you're going to do is
they're going to go to the nearby
Starbucks because there's always a
nearby Starbucks and you're going to use
your Triple A app to get a an object
that represents your service call and
you're gonna put that object on your IOT
desktop and Triple A is going to say we
need access to your spare tire and so
you're gonna click on the icon for your
car key and you're gonna drag the trunk
label off to that icon okay if your
spare tire happened to the backseat you
draw the unlock instead of the trunk and
then Triple A says we want to let you
know when your tire has been changed and
so you click on the icon for your phone
and you drag the text label over okay
now Triple A can take that o cap for the
trunk transfer it to the cut to the
company and the company can transfer it
to the exact driver that's going to
change your tire Triple A will probably
keep your phone information itself when
your tire is changed they will text you
and then you know to go back to your car
it's all very nice and when you click on
the icon for the service call you see
everything you've delegated to it
drag it off the desktop and all those
permissions are revoked that simple okay
I don't think managing fine-grained
permissions is a problem because of this
idea of combining acts of designation
with acts of authorization all right how
are we gonna do this now how are we
gonna get that's really very simple
we're gonna start from scratch we're
gonna throw away all our software we're
gonna fire all our programmers we're
only gonna hire new ones who program in
Haskell and can tell you what the heck a
monad is still waiting for that one and
then we'll just rewrite everything
I see a lot of smiles you don't think
that's gonna work and probably not so I
think what we can do though is work
backwards IOT is the Wild Wild West
stuff is being rewritten all the time
let's just restart with an o cap
framework instead of a mainframe
framework right this is something we can
do within a year
30% of the devices will be o cap and
within five years they'll all be okay
maybe not the refrigerator that you just
bought but but most in raw numbers it
will be virtually everything then let's
look at the micro services now we have a
standard out there o auth bearer tokens
which is what I showed you is a standard
there's plenty of companies using it
it's all over the place if we use that
as oh caps for our micro services now
all of a sudden we'd be able to
outsource them we'd get the benefits of
specialisation that we're missing from
the economy today moving down the list
let's do sharing while sharing
presumably is most important in a
distributed environment and so we can
use something like the Google Docs or
even oauth2 to get a good sharing model
now Google Docs and Dropbox don't have
that they made some mistakes what
happens when you try to use something
like oh caps but you don't know you're
doing oh caps you make mistakes I did
that in 1996 I reinvented capable jet
capabilities I made some mistakes some
of those mistakes were interesting had
interesting effects but I still made
some mistakes and you see that in the
way Google Docs and ooofff work they
made some mistakes but we can still use
them as oh caps if we're careful and
then eventually we will move this into
our operating systems and there's plenty
of work the sel for work kernel work the
cherry work is doing a whole stack based
on o caps so there there is a chance
here that we can do this
by the way on the on the the standard
apps running on your standard desktop we
were able to show that you can have the
same user experience even with Oh caps
Marc Stiegler did something called cap
disk and it was almost the exact
experience you'd have on Windows and
everything was ok so it doesn't have to
change the user experience except at the
margins alright
many years ago I took a trip to London
way before there was Google Maps and I
went out one day just sightseeing and I
got lost so I stopped and asked a flower
vendor on the street how to get to my
hotel and she said something that
explains exactly why this transition
that we're gonna have to make is going
to be so hard
Luva she said if i was going there i
wouldn't start from here alright well
that's the talk and now I can take
questions
don't go away cuz you're gonna get the
mic back oh no no the first question is
in the in the case of the cleaner so the
cleaner has an au cap that has a long
duration because that cleaners coming
once a week for many years the cleaner
gives that o cap to somebody else and
with the intention that it's a one-time
use how do you make sure that it's a
one-time use so this comes down to the
question of revocation can you how do
you revoke these things and you notice
haven't said anything about how you do
it right there are many ways to do it
one way is like Oh off does with just
these opaque strings so what the
cleaning lady could do in that
environment she could go to a service
that I got the O cap from in the first
place and say please exchange this for
one that
expire in a day right another way to do
this that oKed that oh aw 'the strain
could actually be a representation of a
digital certificate and so she could
have her long lived Oh cap and she could
say create a new one she wouldn't have
to talk to anybody just do it right on
her own phone create a new one that's
only good for a day or since an o cap
designates an object my door lock she
could create a new one she could go to
this exchange and just get a brand new
one and say when when she was feeling
better maybe she would be in the
hospital for a month she wouldn't want
it to expire in a day when she wanted to
revoke the access to her her substitute
she would just simply tell that door
lock don't honor this one anymore all
right and it just have a list of revoked
once and it just wouldn't honor it if it
came back and there you'd put an
expiration date of a year or something
just so we could throw it away so that
makes perfect sense but the cleaning
person is not the one who wants
protection me my house owner is the one
who wants protection so how as a house
owner do I enforce that the cleaning
person doesn't give the oh cap to John
Joe Harry whatever for however long that
person wants to do how do you prevent
from you how do you prevent the cleaning
person from giving out your key and
making copies and giving them to all
those people it's the exact same problem
though caps can't solve problems that
can't be solved what the Oh cap does
though is we have the responsibility
tracking so whoever uses a no cap or one
derived from it I'm gonna hold my
cleaning lady responsible and it's up to
her to go make sure that nobody does
anything bad because she's gonna be the
one in trouble
and I'll be quick on this one you and
you in the list of
of the kind of progression that you
talked about you skipped one step so
starting about 10 years maybe 12 years
ago the major online players decided
that it was too much friction DIF for
people to log on over and over again so
you can log on to one and then that and
then from there go and carry as if you
have been authenticated by somebody else
and and so there is this kind of
chaining that goes on now and and I
wonder how you see this and and what the
effect of that is going to be on trying
to make the transition you propose so a
lot of people do that for convenience
and it's a really really terrible idea
because now Facebook knows every place
you log on Facebook can decide oh we
don't like you anymore we're going to
revoke you now your luck now you're
locked out of everything and you know
the other problem is that well those are
the two main problems okay so I think
it's a really bad idea it's very
convenient but I don't do it yeah but
but that's still okay because wherever I
authenticate when I come to remember I
said Alice logs on and gets her see list
so however I log in I get my see list
okay so I have two questions also
let me ask them both at the same time
one is what do you think Dropbox has
done wrong as an example and the other
is what do you think about
authentication as a service such as what
octa does which has become very popular
but distinct from Facebook
octa is not an information provider and
a vendor they're just an authentication
provider right so the first question was
what has Dropbox do wrong
they don't give me
the right sharing model so I know
specifically for Google Docs I have to
think twice about Dropbox let me talk
about Google Docs if I share a file with
you rewrite you can reshare it if I
share a file with read you read only you
can't you have to contact me to reshare
it that's a broken model okay that
that's broken in that way also lately at
least Google Docs is always asking me to
log in to Google before let me see the
doc that's a terrible thing what if I
don't have a Google account
that's awful I I don't I don't mean I
drop box at one point did that you know
I don't remember if they still do and
then the second one was what about a
pure authentication provider like octa
this is called an identity provider in
heidi P right and so I would
authenticate to them and they would
prove that I am who I say I am now
normally what that's doing is saying
that I control some email address that's
the way they identify me there's nothing
more to it than that you know there's
there's no fing phone print or DNA
sample or anything like that it's just
they assert that I control some email
address which means my email address is
my username at all these other services
that octa uses what happens if I lose my
email provider out of luck yep
yeah can support multi-factor but I got
to have that first one right if I lose
my email address they can't verify that
I still have it right and my user ID is
the same at every place that's also a
problem for tracking for privacy right
so it's a service as an IDP lots of
smaller companies in particular do not
want to have to build all the
infrastructure for authenticating users
I actually built a tool on something
called parse unfortunately Facebook
bought it and shut him down and they had
something similar where they would do
that on my behalf and that that's fine
but it's once you get in do you get an
access to other access control lists for
all those objects or is there a an act
is there a c-list for every sub
and that's the big difference but how
you authenticate is not part of this
story you had something it's a more
complicated than using okay so so so
point is that the problem isn't so much
the authentication in the access model
as much as the complexity and the
failure of people to recognize that
complexity anniversary of the Aloha net
and the people in the network Cupid
community are an agreement that had
security been designed into computer
network protocols from the beginning you
know with the ARPANET NCP days the TCP
days as well as Aloha net we never would
have delivered anything to you guys
that's that's the fundamental problem
because we don't know necessarily what
we're doing and and the other problem is
the fact that it's a software
engineering recognized thing is you know
people don't put security as a
requirement very early on I absolutely
agree and that example I gave about
password already and used as an example
of we didn't know what we were doing and
if we'd locked in a standard at that
point we would be in a real mess it was
perfectly reasonable not to do it back
then but my point here is what we have
done by stretching the mainframe model
all the way to IOT is the root cause of
many of our problems in a lot of the
complexity I haven't said anything about
network security and and you know
protocols and all that that's a that's
another story one of the things I left
off my list if you want to stay another
hour I've got some thoughts on that but
so that goes for everyone - what's your
opinion of any services in ceará trust
environments I think it's a wonderful
idea you you shouldn't I mean the whole
idea of O Capps is it gives you that
fine-grained control that you want think
of the the policy rules you have to have
at every point in an authentication in a
mainframe type access control system so
one of my friends worked at PayPal and
they were using authentication mechanism
server to server so every server got
digital certain a digital certificate
and would authenticate to the servers it
was supposed to talk to and they would
verify that this was a valid came from a
valid place and every time they stood up
a new server they'd have to update
eighty-seven Ackles on those other
servers before it could come up and
there was always mistakes and services
broke and all that in an oak out model
they would have simply given the new
server oak caps for those ones that was
supposed to talk to and you know you
only have to update the one and that
works so I think it's a matter of not
the authentication itself but what you
do after the authentication that was my
point
again in the in the mainframe model
Alice authenticates and every program
she runs has to get all her permissions
you can't do any better than that
otherwise Alice has to authenticate over
and over again in a no cap model she
logs in once and she gets her Oh caps
and she can use them she can transfer
them to programs running on her behalf
and it just works so it removes a lot of
the complexity that comes from that
environment so back to the household key
you said revoking certificate oak apps
and timing out and all that sort of
stuff does that work I mean
well how do i implement revoking
certainly yeah so this each certificate
has a unique identifier that's standard
and everything I've ever looked at its
standard in sam'l its standard annex a
camel it's standard in in the JSON web
tokens everyone has a gooood just a big
random string hopefully unique so if i
want to revoke one of those those
certificates since the certificate
itself says which object is supposed to
honor it
I just tell that thing don't honor this
certificate anymore that's it okay very
simple and now when it gets sent it's
revoked
the reason you might put a very long
expiration date is so you don't have
unbounded storage of revoke certificates
but the idea is because in Oh cap
designates an object you know who to
tell not to honor it okay one of the
mistakes the OAuth people made because
they didn't know they were reinventing
Oh caps is they had something they
called a multi audience token I could
get an okay token and not know who might
honor it and that breaks the Oh cap
model in a way that makes revocation
very hard and so they put in very short
time outs lifetimes to live they started
with five minutes and that was too short
so they went to a day and then to a week
now they're typically a month right
shows the failure of trying to just use
timeouts you need an explicit revocation
mechanism and if you know exactly who
might honor the token you can tell tell
them not honored now the other thing is
who gets the right to revoke that's
interesting and because we have the
responsibility tracking we can follow
that chain and so when I say to revoke
they just make sure I'm somewhere on
that chain and if I'm on the chain it's
revoked and if it isn't if I'm not I
don't have permission to revoke so it
just falls right out
you seem to posit a distributed model
with independent objects and as few
central points of failure as possible
but you still need a audit in other
kinds of centralized facilities and key
management and that kind of thing so can
you talk about the distribution of roles
and responsibilities so you definitely
need audio audio don't need key
management this is one of the beauties
so I stand up a service and I create the
first certificate with my own private
key that covers all uses of the service
including the management and then I
create a subset token derived from that
one that covers the stuff that users
that have so I'm not going to give away
the management stuff and then that gets
delegated to you and you delegate to
your company so for example we don't
need Federation with this model our
company signed a contract I give your
company a token covering the services
and the contract you create new tokens
delegate to managers managers delegate
to people they present the tokens with
their requests and I know it's
legitimate or not very easily okay now
when I give you a certificate I'm gonna
say I need a public key that I can put
on this certificate so I can validate
that it's being used properly and you
can create one on the fly no key
management this thing you do this and we
build up an onion layer of certificates
nested in certificates I unwind the
thing until I see my own private key no
key management when and when my private
key is compromised that's a reason to
have lifetimes on their certificates but
remember I can revoke the certificate
not the key today I have to revoke
somebody's key right I've given it to
something that a certificate authority
asserts as yours but that's used for
many purposes that's a disaster for you
right here I'm revoking a one off key
it's much simpler
so does does your approach mandate a
third party to make the whole system
work it doesn't have to be an authority
that provides this service to make this
whole thing work no there doesn't I mean
I could do it myself as I said I can
create a certificate out of whole cloth
that covers my service I can ask you for
a one-off public key and hand it to you
know third party involved now there are
places so for example ooofff is designed
for users sitting at browsers and users
sitting at browsers don't want to see
random strings so they have a service
that does it for them but that's
optional
I can certainly generate a no cap so for
example in in the Salesforce work when I
create a new resource I create a no cap
for it just in the code right there it's
just a JavaScript reference that's an
okay and I can pass it around I can even
send it to other JavaScript objects so
no you can use one if you want but it's
not necessary and in fact it's probably
less necessary now on the audit this
this is particularly interesting and
this is where the responsibility
tracking comes in because we can't do a
proper audit today we don't know why an
admin made a change in an access control
list with oh caps we can follow the
responsibility tracking so I contend we
get meaningful audits instead of what we
have today
so I'm back at the third party again so
you know maybe I can do that but my wife
my grandmother can is this going to be
within the capability of non technically
sophisticated people to do without a
central authority when I showed you that
flat tire example I clicked on the icon
for the trunk down my car
software that ran there created the
Ocampa not your mother that that icon
interface seems intuitive to you it's
not intuitive to a large proportion of
the population of the planet and
including my wife she does not know how
to use an icon based system I had I had
the same problem with my wife she got
very confused about icon based systems
but maybe that's a problem that will
cure itself because everything is these
days but so it's funny story I gave this
talk at Bay Lisa these Lisa is the large
infrastructure systems administrators
talk and before the talk I was in earth
I was introduced to the organizers
mother and so I put that up and after
the talk I said well as a non-technical
person do you think you could manage
that and she says oh I've been a data
center sysadmin for 25 years I
[Music]
embarrassed myself oh yeah she is as a
command line I so I embarrassed myself
and I don't make that assumption anymore
but if point-and-click is too hard I
have no answer but if point-and-click
works I don't need a central authority
because the software inside the
application will do it however your wife
inter interacts with an application she
has to be able to say what it is she
wants to do she wants to open this web
page she wants to open that application
that's an act of designation
she can handle a you know an ID user ID
and password that for her is intuitive
but if she is on Amazon and wants to buy
something she clicks on it she doesn't
okay well then I'm then she's not can't
do it for her okay but maybe most other
people certainly that guy's mother so so
back to revocation and things you lose
your private key and you want to revoke
everything how does your door lock know
that you did this so I have so did I
lose my private key or do I think it was
compromised
compromised my keys so I still have it
so now I can sign a request send it to
the door lock and say revoke anything
derived from that private key that
private key okay just revoke it and then
they say and I can also use it to
certify a new key so key I have to have
key management in the sense of managing
your own keys you have to protect your
private key you have to way have a way
of recovery from compromise typically
they expire the more they're used their
standard software that does that we
don't need key management in the sense
of you know the certificate authorities
and all that infrastructure so I like to
say that PK is fine it's the I that's
the problem you were just talking with
the guy who worked for the company that
brought us icons to the world by the way
I just wanted to add something about the
icon thing as a historical note and it's
the fact that you used to work for as
did he at one time IBM and Dec who in
the past the certain well we're gonna
speak to our computer or type to our
computer in natural language and then
artificial intelligence will obviously
voice recognize all our commands and our
intents and Doug Engelbart
particular was particularly perturbed
because certain people have the so
called artificial intelligence community
because less earnest isn't here today to
debris an issue with that you know we
don't have that stuff and yet people
claim we have artificial intelligence so
just a side note for language yeah well
talking to the computer would be really
annoying with you because you're always
working on your computer while I'm
speaking and secondly now this came up
this came up when my kid was in fourth
grade they weren't they didn't want to
teach them cursive and we said well
who's going to sign the checks and they
said Oh we'll take an X well how are
they going to take notes when they get
to college oh they'll talk to their
computers can you imagine a lecture hall
with 300 students tall talking to their
computers to take notes it's ridiculous
so there's going to be some non voice
interaction with the device maybe it'll
be maybe it'll be a brain reading system
yeah so so you're saying there was a PDA
that had voice recognition with a backup
if you couldn't speak so all of this the
revoking things depends on time working
sorry the timing out things depends on
time and checking things that expire and
of things you got any ideas on how to
make sure time is correct on everybody
it time doesn't have to be correct on
everybody it just has to be good enough
on the object the place where the object
resides so in fact the way I implemented
timeouts was I had a demon that would
revoke the capability when its clock
said to and it was only the demons clock
that mattered so I didn't have this
problem of distributed clocks and times
and
I made a terrible mistake once would
make files and local times I was working
on a distributed supercomputer New York
Texas and San Jose and I did make and
everything built and I said make again
and two-thirds of the stuff built again
and I said make again and two-thirds of
this stuff built again then it was five
o'clock so I went home I came in the
next morning I said making nothing don't
well at the time stamps we the the files
were marked with local time not not not
not not yet not GMT and so I made a
mistake with time so I'm sensitive to
those issues but that's the way I
implement the timeouts yeah but if if it
times out on your machine and you want
to talk to the door that assumes that
the network is working that's one reason
why I mean if the network isn't working
I can't revoke anyway there's always a
race between the decision to revoke and
the in a distributed system and the
actual revocation and lots of things can
make that shorter or longer I can't fix
that but if you wanted to revoke
somebody's public key or you wanted to
revoke and take an entry out of an Akal
you'd have the exact same problem so oak
apps don't cure cancer they don't solve
all problems in distributed systems but
they simplify access control is my
contention so unreal occasion again so
if I understood you correctly you said
if if my if I think my key is
compromised then I can go to the door
and tell it not to accept any okay you
derive from that key wait a minute let
me get to my question so how can can the
the person who has or and the entity
that has compromised my key also send a
message to the and then and then I'm
locked out and how do I recover yeah
that's that's a problem I can't solve
that one tough watch
go caps don't solve that problem if you
lose your key you're in trouble you
gotta have other mechanisms to protect
yourself you could have a backup key you
could have an emergency key that's kept
in a locked vault offline like like all
the big vendors do and that's your
emergency key that says you know the
door lock will recognize it and that's
permanent and it never goes away or
whatever I mean but these are standard
mechanisms any times using public keys
so I have nothing extra to say about
that wherever you want you to protect
where's your private key stored wherever
you want you to protect it however you
do it today but the nice part is that if
you have a lot of these one-off keys
that pub private key controls that one
permission I have and this other one
controls this other one permission if
one of them it's compromised I haven't
lost my whole life unlike if it's a
certificate authority and my one and
only key and everything's tied to it
I've been concerned you know but what
happens and emergency services type
situations with power failures and
network networks going down and how how
does this survive fail soft yep that's
that's a real problem on I was on the
emergency evacuation squad when I worked
at IBM and the question was in an
earthquake do the doors to the computer
room you know fail open or fail walked
right that's a useful discussion right I
don't think Oh caps changes that at all
you've got to have in fact a place where
it's really important is in medical so
let's say we built the whole system for
doing electronic medical records managed
bio caps okay well what happens if you
go into the emergency room well you know
you're in the swimming pool and you
don't have your your smart card with you
with your keys on it to delegate the
well there's a break glass mechanism
right and it's carefully audited bla bla
bla so but oh caps make no difference on
that one way or the other okay thank you